European companies export around 90
billion euros worth of goods and
services to Japan every year Parliament
is set to vote on a trade deal between
the EU and Japan which would remove
barriers facilitating trade the
imprisoned Ukrainian filmmaker oleg
sentsov will be awarded the 2018
Sakharov Prize for freedom of thought he
was sentenced to 20 years in a penal
colony in Russia after being accused of
plotting terrorist acts Parliament calls
for his immediate release parliament
members will debate the future of Europe
with Cypriot president nikos anastasi
Avice it will be the 14th debate in the
series mep s are set to adopt the
recommendations of Parliament's special
committee on terrorism the report calls
for more cooperation between security
services and urges member states to
share information millions of European
workers are exposed to cancer-causing
agents in the workplace Parliament will
vote on adding 8 chemicals to the list
of known carcinogens and mutagens and
setting limits for exposure